Bitte schön.
Okay. Okay. Guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Frau Kardasch. Ich bin als Assistentätich auf dieser Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen auf das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, klar. Hauptsache irgendeinem.
Es hilft mir.
Okay. Und ich würde zunächst ein paar Allgemeine zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Marga Sauter.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname Buch stabilen?
Ja, der Vorname ist Marga M-A-R-G-A und der Familienname ist Sauter S-A-U-T-E-R.
T-E-R.
Frau Sauter, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt. Ich bin im März 60 geworden.
Und wann sind Sie genergert geworden?
Am 1. März 64.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin so 1,64.
Äh, 64. Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich wiege so ungefähr 70, 71 Kilo.
Okay. Wer ist Ihre Hausärztin oder Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Döpfer.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich darf ich kein Penicillin bekommen.
Da habe ich mal sehr heftig so eine Hautausschlag bekommen.
Das darf ich also nicht noch mal benutzen.
Und wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Beispiellich, ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen.
Das hat gestern Abend nach dem Abendessen angefangen.
Es sind so richtige Wellen sind, die da ankommen.
Mir ist so schlecht,
ich konnte heute noch gar nichts essen.
Und seit heute Morgen habe ich auch einen wahnsinnigen Durchfall. Das fließt nur so weg und ist so
ganz wässrige Zeug und ich fühle mich so wahnsinnig schlecht. Ich habe auch gestern Abend, hatte ich mit
einmal das Gefühl, dass ich so friere und so, dann habe ich mal Fieber gemessen. Dann hatte ich
tatsächlich auch 38,4 Temperatur und schlecht ist mir. Also ich darf an Essen überhaupt gar nicht denken.
Okay. Und Frau Sauter, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen seit gestern?
Ja, nach dem Abendessen fing das an. Okay. Was haben Sie am Abend gegessen?
Ja, ich habe ein Mettbrötchen gegessen. Wissen Sie so mit rohem Fleisch und Zwiebel und mit Tomate
und ich darf gar nicht dran denken. Das Einzige, was mir so ein bisschen geholfen hat,
ich habe mir dann heute Nacht eine Wärmflasche geholt und dann ging es mir ein klein bisschen
besser. Da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich nicht mehr so furchtbar schatterig und kalt bin.
Dann habe ich auch ein paar Stunden geschlafen, aber zwischendurch musste ich immer raus,
weil ich mich übergeben musste und dann hatte ich so seit heute früh um fünf habe ich solchen
Durchfall also ganz schlimm. Okay. Und wo ist die Genauchschmerzen?
Naja, so, ich denke mal so im Magenbereich, also oberhalb vom Bauchnavel so. Da tut es ganz doll wie.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genauer beschreiben? Ist es eine Stechen, Brennen oder
krampfartige Schmerzen? Ja, krampfartig würde ich eher sagen, ja. Und das macht auch immer so,
also so Wellen, dass das anschwillt und dann wird es wieder besser. Und also so ein bisschen
Erleichterung hat das jeweils gebracht, nachdem ich mich übergeben habe. Ja, und dann ging es mir,
hatte ich so das Gefühl, kann ein bisschen durchatmen. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel auch die
Toilette muss, dann zieht es im ganzen Bauch und und der Humort und ja, da tut dann auch der Unterbauch
weh. Okay, habe ich das richtig verstanden? Schözralende Schmerzen in den ganzen Bauch aus.
Sie sind im ganzen Bauch, ja, ja, ja. Gibt es etwas, dass Ihre Schmerzen lindert außer dieser
Wärmeflasche? Ja, ich habe halt nichts gegessen. Ich denke mal, das war das Beste, was ich tun konnte,
ja. Ich habe versucht, ein bisschen Tee zu trinken, aber der ist gleich wieder rausgekommen. Und dann
habe ich gar nichts mehr getrunken. Aber jetzt fühle ich mich total schlapp und kraftlos.
Und wie sieht das Elbruchen aus? Ja, das ist so gelblich und halt die Reste von dem,
von dem, was ich gegessen habe. Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerz-Kadafoneis?
Bin es 10? 1 ist sehr leicht und Schmerzen, 10 ist sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht.
Oh, die sind bestimmt so bei 7, 8 würde ich sagen, ja. Das sind wirklich sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen.
Okay, wenn diese Welle kommt, oder? Schmerz-Welle kommt. Ja, ja, ja.
Und wenn es keine Schmerz-Attacken gibt? Ja, in der Zwischenzeit vielleicht so,
weil 6 bis 7 vielleicht, so eine Stufe weniger. Hatten Sie so etwas schon früher?
Ja, also ich kenne das wohl. Ich habe so einen Reizmagen, sagt man, ja, dass ich also
ein bisschen empfindlich reagiere, wenn ich fettige Sachen esse oder wenn ich was besonders scharfes
esse oder manchmal reagiert er auch ein bisschen sauer, wenn ich Schokolage esse und so, aber
eigentlich habe ich, habe ich da sonst solche Probleme, wie jetzt habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, Sie haben mir erzählt, dass Ihre Schmerzen in den Oberbauch angefangen.
Ja. Gibt es eine bestimmte Art, rechter oder linke Seite oder war es in der Mitte?
Nee, das ist in der Mitte, würde ich sagen. Okay.
Hat Ihre Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Ich würde sagen, das hat sehr plötzlich angefangen.
Sie haben mir gesagt, das ging mit einmal los, ja.
Aber zum 1. Mal. Bitte?
Zum 1. Mal fühlen Sie sich so stark geschmärzt.
Ja, ja, also so etwas habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Sie haben erzählt, dass Sie Fieber haben, 8C834, und haben Sie in Mund gemessen oder unter der Achsel?
Nein, unter der Achsel habe ich gemessen.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder hatten Sie Schwarz vor den Augen?
Nee, das war eigentlich nicht, nein.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzter Zeit merklich verändert?
Nein, das ist immer gleich.
Und wie ist die Farbe des Stuhlgangs?
Das war ganz flüssig und das war so hellrot verfärbt.
Hellrot?
Und Sie haben drinnen Blut gesehen, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Blut war, vielleicht war das auch Essensreste, keine Ahnung,
dass das einfach nur so durchgerauscht ist.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasser lassen?
Meinen Sie normalerweise oder wie?
Normalerweise oder seid ein Quater?
Nein, eigentlich auch nicht.
Das kommt halt dann mit, wenn ich sowieso auf die Toilette gehe.
Haben Sie Kartenschweiß?
Nein, eigentlich war es nachts eher so, dass mir kalt war,
aber so kalt schweiß ich war das eigentlich nicht.
Leiten Sie unter Schlafstörungen?
Manchmal bin ich so ein bisschen unruhig und dann nehme ich Maldrian.
Ist das ein Tee?
Ja, das sind, die sind so Tropfen, ne?
Tropfen.
Maldrian Tropfen.
Leiten Sie an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, eben wie gesagt, diese Reizmagen hat mein Arzt mal gesagt,
also ich müsste ein bisschen vorsichtiger essen.
Und ich habe auch so einen chronischen Husten.
Ich rauch halt viel, bin da und hab vor allem früher viel geraucht.
Also muss ich schon oft husten, also bald irgendwas,
weil ich ein bisschen Erkältung hab, habe ich sofort harnäckigen Husten.
Und wenn ich mich verschlucke, huste ich auch immer ganz doll.
Aber das ist eigentlich so, dass ich ständig ein bisschen Husten hab.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen außer die E-Säe?
Eigentlich.
Bin ich so immer gut zu Gast gekommen?
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ne, ne Operation hatte ich nicht.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Wie gesagt, diese Baldreandropfen, wenn ich so ein bisschen unruhig bin
und wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe, dann nehme ich Aspirin.
Das kann ich mir nicht erlauben mit Kopfschmerzen in der Gegend rumzurennen.
In den letzten Wochen haben Sie Aspirin eingenommen oder Ibuprofen?
Ja, manchmal habe ich Aspirin genommen, weil ich Kopfschmerzen hatte.
Sie haben mir schon erzählt, dass Sie rauchen.
Und wie viel Zigarette am Tag und seit wieviel Jahren rauchen Sie?
Ja, also jetzt rauche ich nicht mehr so viel.
Ich habe viele Jahre, also ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Aber seit man im Taxi nicht mehr rauchen darf, also das ist ja ganz streng geworden.
Da komme ich gar nicht mehr dazu.
Da rauche ich vielleicht noch so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag, so seit zehn Jahren würde ich sagen.
Und vor diesem zehn Jahr, wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, da habe ich bestimmt 20 Jahre ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also abends, wenn ich Feierabend habe, dann trinke ich vielleicht so pro Woche zwei Gläser Wein.
Manchmal im Sommer, wenn es so warm ist und man viel Durst hat, trinke ich auch mal eine Flasche Bier.
Aber nicht viel Alkohol.
Und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Es ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Manchmal kommen Kunden und wollen irgendwo hinfahren, wo man Drogen kaufen kann.
Aber nee, nee, ich habe damit nichts zu tun.
Sind Sie voll geimpft?
Ich bin geimpft, ja. Sie meinen gegen Corona oder wie?
Da bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise nach Ausland gemacht?
Nein, nein.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nee, die sind beide früh gestorben. Mein Vater hatte schon mit 55 ein Herzinfarkt.
Und meine Mutter, die war, die ist auch nicht alt geworden, die war 65.
Und dann hatte die Brustkrebs. Und dann ist sie auch ganz schnell gestorben.
Es tut mir leid. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister habe ich nicht, nein, ich war ein so ein Kind.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Taxifahrerin.
Und sind Sie feiereiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter habe ich, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Nun kann man leider nicht sagen, nee, die, die hatten, die hatten mit Drogen angefangen, ja.
Und die ist aktuell in dem, in so einem Metadonprogramm drin.
Und muss sich da regelmäßig ihre Ersatzmedikamente abholen.
Und das macht mir natürlich auch große Sorgen.
Deswegen kann ich manchmal nicht schlafen, ne?
Ich hoffe, dass in der Laufe der Zeit besser wird.
Ja, das hoffe ich auch, ja.
Okay. Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Siehst du aus, nee. Also Sport mache ich nur wirklich nicht. Nein.
Sind Sie schon in Männerpausen?
Ja, klar.
Ich würde gerne fragen, diese Brot gestern Abendessen.
Ich würde gerne noch ein paar Fragen stellen.
Und haben Sie dieses Brot zu Hause vorbereitet oder haben Sie das gekauft?
Ich habe das zu Hause gegessen, ja.
Und gab es niemand, das mit ihnen zusammen gegessen?
Nee, das habe ich alleine gegessen.
Alleine gegessen, okay.
Wie gesagt, ich lebe alleine. Meine Tochter ist nicht, ist nicht bei mir.
Und also ich habe alleine für mich das Essen gemacht.
Okay. Haben Sie das Fleisch frisch gekauft, oder das war von?
Das habe ich morgens gekauft und dann in den Kühlschrank getan.
Okay.
Ja, vielleicht war das am Morgen schon nicht mehr ganz frisch.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es daran liegt.
Darf gar nicht daran denken, an das Brot vielleicht.
Okay.
Von meiner Seite, ich habe die ganze Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich glaube, ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr irgendwas sagen.
Ich bin mir so schlecht.
Ich habe nur das aufhört, dass Sie mir irgendwas geben,
dass diese Schmerzen und diese Übelkeit lachen lässt.
Okay.
Und ich würde gerne eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Danach werde ich Sie sofort einen Medikament gegen Ihre Beschwerden geben.
Das wäre gut, ja.
Okay.
Ich denke, das wäre gut.
Eine annemnitzgezüge für uns und Kollegen.
Haben Sie Kollegen oder Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit langem Reismagen an den Reismagen gelitten haben.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Magenspiegelung durchgeführt?
Nein, das ist damals nicht gemacht worden.
Danke.
Und eben kamen schriftlich noch die Frage rein,
ob andere Leute in der Familie ähnliche Beschwerden haben.
Ich habe gesagt, ich lebe alleine und ich habe auch alleine gegessen.
Insofern ist dann niemand, der auch krank ist.
Was ist das?
Eine annemnitzgezüge, die nicht gefragt hat.
Sie hat gefragt, ob ich in der Minupause bin.
Okay.
Voroperation gefragt, oder?
Voroperation hat sie gefragt, ja.
Okay.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind fertig.
Ich denke auch, das war vollständig.
Gut.
Danke.
Sie sind auch, was mir gut gefallen hat, sie sind immer eingegangen auf das,
was ich schon gesagt habe.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass das und das, wie ist es denn damit?
Also, da hat man gemerkt, sie haben zugehört und waren auf die
Patientin eingestellt, haben sie es schön gemacht.
Okay, mögen Sie schon als Gespräch starten?
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Hallo.
Wir haben eine neue Patientin.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen, Sie vorstellen.
Und Frau Sauter, 60 Jahre alt, sie stellte heute bei uns wegen
starken Bauchschmerzen.
Diese Beschwerden besteht seit gestern Abend.
Sie hat 3 Mal Übelkeit,
nach dem Abendessen.
Sie hat auch Übelkeit, starke Vomitus.
Und sie hat 3 Mal Übelkeit.
Nein, sie hat 3 Mal, Entschuldigung, diese Fachwürze.
Und sie leitet sich 3 Mal übergeben.
Sie berichtet über 3 Malige Mäßes.
Und diese Schmerzen hat im Oberhalb der Bauch angefangen
und generals in den ganzen Bauch aus.
Und Schmerzart ist krampfartig
und auf die Schmerzintensität liegt
Ich spürte seit die Zeit 7 oder 8 von 10 und sie hat mir erzählt, dass sie warme Fläche geholfen hat.
Und sie hatte früher Reisenmagen beschwerden. Sie hatte auch Bauchschmerzen nach dem Viertige Essen.
Aber diese Schmerzen hatte sie noch nie.
In dieser Form noch nicht, okay.
Ja, seit gestern Abend sie konnte nichts essen wegen der Schmerzen.
Und sie fühlt sich fühlig, sie hat auch Fieber gemessen.
Sie hat auch Schifffrost, sie hat sehr, sehr starke und starke Diare.
Sie berichtete, dass sie im Stuhlgang früssig und hell-rote Bereiche gesehen hat.
hat und sie leidet unter chronische Brunschitis. Sie ist niemals operiert worden. Sie nimmt
baldren Tropfen einzuschlafen. Regelmäßig? Bei Bedarf. Und wenn sie Schlafprobleme hat,
Schlafstörung hat. Sie nimmt auch gelegentlich Aspirin ein, aber in dieser Woche hat sie
keine Angenommen. Und sie ist Raubrenn ungefähr 25 Packungsjahr. Sie trinkt Alkohol pro Woche.
Zwei Gläserwein. Drogenkonsum wurde verfeinert. Im Stadius vollständig. Sie hat keine Reise
ins Ausland gemacht. Bei der Familienanamnese, bei der Mutter Mama Katzinom, die Mutter an Mama Katzinom
verstorben. Der Vater an Myokadinfarkt verstorben. Sie ist Taxifahrerin, geschieden, lebt alleine,
hat einen Kind und treibt keinen Sport. Sie ist jetzt in Männerpause. Diese anamnistische
Angabe deutet auf einen bakteriellen Darminfektion hin. Magendarminfektion hin. Was könnte es sonst
noch sein, differential Diagnostik? Ja, Peptis Ulcus kann sein und kann auch Darm-Magenblutung.
Ah, ja, okay. Ja, okay, gut. Was machen Sie weiter, um die Patientin zu untersuchen?
Ich würde gerne eine Blutabnahme und Stuhlprobe machen. Ah, ja, okay, gut. Was soll im Blutuntersuch
werden? Entsündungsparameter, großes Blutpint, Leukositen und ich würde gerne auch Bauch-Brundtgen
veranlassen. Ne, noch mal zum Blut, was noch? Entsündungsparameter habe ich schon gesagt,
glaube ich. Und in CAP, BSG, Prokalzitonin und Leukositen und ja. Und Verumständen,
Leberwerte? Leberwerte auch, ja. Genau. Weil es ist Stuhldiagnostik auf Bakterien, ja. Ja.
Okay, gut. Und welche weiteren Untersuchungen, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, worauf achten
Sie da? Bauchuntersuchung, Abwehrspannung und ja. Auf was hören Sie? Ja, erhöfte
Darmgeräusche. Ja, genau. Ja. Und das noch Bauchrundtgen auch würde ich auch veranlassen,
um eine Pepticulcusperforation auszuschließen. Perforation, okay, ja. Weil sie sehr starke
Schmerzen auch zwischen Schmerzattacken hat. Ja, genau. Aber was wäre sonst das erste
Sonorophyll? Ja, genau, dass man erst mal guckt, ob man da irgendwas sieht und man freie Flüssigkeit
sieht, ne? Genau. Und ja, wie wäre denn die Therapie, wenn sie tatsächlich jetzt eine bakterielle
Mageninfektion hat? Würden Sie die Patientestationär aufnehmen? Weil sie keine Morbideerkrankungen
hat, würde ich gerne jetzt als Taxiwärter eine Flüssigkeitsangabe machen, weil sie konnte
keine Essen auftragen. Sie konnte nicht essen, also brauchst du eine Medizogzugang? Ja, ja.
Ich würde gerne auch mit dem Metronidazolantviotikum Therapie anfangen. Okay. Und ich würde gerne
auch Elektrolytik... Was geben Sie gegen die Schmerzen? Ja, und Spasmolite. Genau, damit
der Krempfe weggehen. Ja, und Panzerpfosol würde ich gerne auch geben. Ah ja, sehr gut.
Gegen MS ist auch Antimethikum. Antimethik. Ja, sie wird Ihnen dankbar sein für alles,
was Sie tun. Ja, gut. Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufen über die Patientin, insbesondere
über die Laborergebnis? Ich bin gespannt, was wir für ein Ergebnis vor allen Dingen
von der Darmen, von der Stuhluntersuchung bekommen, ob die tatsächlich etwas finden
da im Labor. Und wenn die Patientin noch stationär ist, kann ich mir die ja morgen angucken.
Gut, vielen Dank. Danke schön. Ja, also da fehlt ja nichts dran, würde ich mal sagen.
Das war ein ich sehr, sehr schön gemacht. Eine so ein bisschen grammatikalisch habe ich
wie immer ein bisschen was zu meckern. Auf den Blick, sie hat gesagt, dass sie die Wärmflasche
geholfen hat. Natürlich hat ihr die Wärmflasche geholfen. Ja, ja. Dann haben sie gesagt,
Sie stellte heute wegen Bauchschmerzen vor. Trendbares Verb irgendwann am Ende von dem
ganzen Sermon muss das vor noch kommen. Also, das vergessen viele. Sie sind nicht alleine mit diesem
Problem. Das ist meine Rede seit, seit ich diese Anamesen mache, seit Jahre. Sie stellte sich wegen
und dann kommt ganz viel und dann wissen sie nicht mehr, was sie am Anfang schon gesagt haben.
Und dann vergessen sie es. Machen sie am Anfang nicht so viel und denken sie aber,
ich daran den Satz richtig zu Ende zu bringen. Gut. Und dann, was ich ein bisschen unvermittelt
fand, das war ihre Formulierung für die Familienanamnese. Bei der Familienanamnese,
Vater mit 55 Jahren am Herbst, ist er gestorben. Also, bei der Frage nach der oder bei der
Familienanamnese ergab sich, dass der Vater oder gab die Patientin an, dass ihr Vater im Alter von
55 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben sei. Ja, also da muss ein richtiger Satz draus werden. Ja,
oder man sagt, familienanamnistisch ergab sich und dann das Doppelpunkt Vater mit 55. Aber es
ist, ich denke immer, wenn man es vorträgt, ist es noch mal anders als wenn man einen schriftlichen
Text macht. Ja, wenn ich einen schriftlichen Bericht mache, da steht dann, Familie an
amnese Doppelpunkt, Vater mit 55 Jahren am Herzinfarkt gestorben, Mutter mit 65 an
meinem Magazinum. Ja, so. Aber wenn ich das jemand mir erzähle, muss ich das in einen richtigen
Satz bringen. Ja, und da würde man dann eben sagen, im Rahmen der Familienanamnese gab
die Patientin an oder bei der Familienanamnese erwähnte die Patientin das so. Was sie nicht
gesagt haben, was aber ja ganz sicher ein Problem für die Patientin ist, dass die Tochter,
ihre einzige Tochter, einzige Angehörige sozusagen, die ist geschienen von ihrem Mann, dass die Drogen
abhängig ist und im Methadonprogramm ist. Das ist sicherlich so was. Sie haben zwar sehr nett
gesagt, oh, ich hoffe, dass das bald besser wird. Der Patientin ging über, fand ich nett. Ja,
aber das hätten sie vielleicht noch gegen im Arztgespräch erwähnen müssen. Aber sonst
würde ich sagen, war das sehr, sehr vollständig. Ja. Ich habe nicht viel daran zum Bekannten.
Entschuldigung, ich denke, die Anämnese ist vollständig, aber wir verwenden ein paar Medizinische
Wörter, wie zum Beispiel der Patient hat gesagt, Reismagen, wir müssen funktionelle Dispepsis sagen.
Der Patient hat gesagt, Hel, Rote, Gaeta, wir müssen Melena fragen, zum Beispiel,
Hauptauschlag, Exantem und der Patient hat gesagt, Magenbereich und
Was? Und Unterbauch. Ja, wir müssen epigastisch und umlikal schmerzen. Und ganzer Bauch, wir müssen
die Füsse sagen und deswegen alles gut andere. Ja, das sind gute Tipps noch mal, wobei Sie wissen,
das wird von Prüfung zu Prüfung unterschiedlich gesehen. Die einen wollen die Pachtbegriffe
und die anderen wollen sie nicht. Wer weiß, was Sie für einen Prüfer kriegen. Ich hoffe,
einen netten und geschalten und der sie so aufhängt, wie alles ist. Ja, wunderbar. Gut.
Man ist gut gemacht hat und ich hoffe, dass die Prüfung, dass ihre Prüfung bestanden wird.
Bestehen wird, ja. Aber wir sind ars und deswegen verwenden wir immer Medizinische Wörter.
Ja, es sei denn, es sei denn, man bezieht sich auf das, was zum Beispiel ein Patient gesagt hat,
ja, wenn man das sozusagen in Anführungsstrichen setzt, ja, dass man sagt, die Patientin hat gesagt,
was, was ich im Oberbauch tut, ist ihr wie oder oberhalb des Bauchnames, ist ihr wie. Ja,
also dann kann man dann sagen, sie beschreibt epigastrische Schmerzen. Ja, so. Das ist schon
schon richtig. Aber wie gesagt, einige Prüfer sind gar nicht so wild auf die, auf die
Fachterminologie. Gut.